thanks for watching this video from
spectator TV if you enjoy what we do
here do subscribe to our YouTube channel
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss a video
[Music]
are some breads falling out of love with
Germany with a rising Hardline
right-wing party and a slowing economy
it seems like Germany has just as many
challenges as any other country in this
week's magazine William Cook asks
whether some Brits haven't been
oversimplifying the country he joins me
now
William Cook thank you so much for
coming on to spectator TV and you write
in your piece that liberal Britain has
fallen out of love with Germany rather
rapidly recently and first of all can we
talk about what's happened in Germany to
make people reconsider their rather Rosy
abuse of the country certainly well I
mean you know three things have happened
really
um one is that Marcos left and this kind
of Talisman of of uh the kind of Liberal
Liberal left in Britain kind of exited
the stage so it may be there Mitty yeah
they're they're quite isn't quite this
kind of totem pole for for kind of
progressive uh Britain's uh to look at
and get slightly dewey-eyed about
anymore
um the afd alternative for Deutschland
has been on the Rise
um to what extent that is a hard left
party or a far right part a hard right
party or a far-right party is a matter
of debate but it certainly caused quite
a lot of this quiet in Germany and also
in in Britain certainly among people on
the kind of uh Progressive uh side of
politics here uh and also the third
thing I think is the um the German
economies had a Slowdown
um
it's Germany's been in recession will be
it from a pretty
um Big Head Start
um my my view is that this is a cycle
and it's going to come out of it but
nevertheless I mean I think I think it's
kind of re-evaluation really I don't
think things are quite as bad in Germany
as the papers like to make out but
equally I also don't think they were
quite as good as they were before so I
think you know it's a kind of wake-up
call for for for people in Britain uh
you know things things were not it's a
big complex country with
80 something million people living there
and a lot of Industry a lot of big
cities a lot of small towns and it's got
a lot of the same problems that Britain
has and I think you know Britain's are
kind of coming around to that idea yeah
because there was a moment maybe
especially durian before brexit where
you know people were thinking you know
articles and books written to the name
of what does Germany get right all of
these kind of things like what can we
learn from Germany the real leader of
Europe and all that sort of stuff yeah
why Germans do it better I mean you know
that was a sort of convenient Hook and
the books actually John Captain looks
actually kind of more more kind of
nuanced than that but um even so I mean
it was it was it was a nice idea wasn't
it I mean it was partly because we were
all stuck in lockdown and kind of
watching the tally and obsessing about
the news and of course Trump was was you
know going wild on Twitter and there was
this kind of Log Jam in the uh British
system in in the post-brexit um era
particularly with Theresa May and then
after the Theresa May Log Jam you had
the Boris Johnson roller coaster and
people who at the time who didn't want
either to be in this gridlock with
Theresa May or in this kind of rather
chaotic and unpredictable setting with
with Johnson and then looking across the
pond and seeing trunk going on Twitter
and saying all sorts of stuff Merkel
looked like the only grown-up in the
room at times and um you know some of
that Sheen has come off another big
thing that's changed of course with
regard to Merkel is that one of the few
things that Trump got right possibly a
stock clock tells the right time twice a
day is that you know he he he he did
sound off about Germany's dependence on
fossil fuels Russian fossil fuels in
particular and Germany's actually done a
u-turn on that pretty quick and it's
it's quite remarkable how how quickly
they've changed tack but you've got to
say he was he was kind of right and um
you know it was a it was some
unnecessary kind of change I think the
invasion of Ukraine did mean that
Germany set to rethink and you know it
didn't kind of doesn't look like it's
kind of way out in front the way it did
to people before yeah a bit of a naive
point of view I think but I mean it was
understandable like I say if you're
stuck in lockdown glued to the tally and
all you've got to watch is 24-hour news
and you see Merkel shuffling around
looking
um you know business-like and you see
Trump and Johnson and and mail all kind
of doing their different things it's a
it's a natural conclusion to come to but
I think some of the Sheen has come off
the Merkel Legacy uh certainly and I
think it's always been more of a
reflection of domestic politics here
where we think of foreign countries
right I mean it's almost less about
Germany itself our view of Germany and
more about all that projects will be
reflected on domestic politics here
because it was more oh look how bad
brexit is or look how bad Trump is look
how stable they are with no actual
interest in understanding Germany to the
degree for example that you do and
you're writing your piece for example
the difference between Berlin and
Countryside the difference between
different demographics in Germany all of
these things not actually what people
are interested in well I'm still just
interested in Germany is a foil for the
UK yeah and I think that as you said
that applies to a lot of countries
America as well for instance you know
it's it's tempting to kind of look for
what we want to find in these countries
and certainly if you go to Germany yes
you can go to Berlin or cologne or
Hamburg and meet a certain kind of
demographic and come back with a
completely different uh point of view
than if you go to small towns or
Villages or the countryside or or
Farmland in Bavaria or whatever it's a
very very uh diverse place and uh rather
like America I think I think America is
a helpful analogy I mean it's a it's a
federal system rather like America local
politics Regional politics is possibly
more important to a lot of Germans than
National politics you know their their
state capital is their Capital Northern
Berlin you know they're they're they're
kind of you wouldn't say looking inwards
but they're they're they're often rooted
in their in their own communities and
it's it's not like all Germans are
berliners by any means yes absolutely
and it's interesting that as Merkel
Legacy is being reevaluated now in the
years since she has left office in
Russia you mentioned is one way in which
it's being reevaluated I also think you
know I write about China look at China
when you look at Germany's China policy
that I think also has a some some level
of re-evaluation that will come in the
future you look at the comprehensive
agreement on investment which is a
Chinese EU Financial deal pushed through
by Merkel very much but at the moment
it's dead in the water because the
parliament will not ratify it and that's
again another miracle Legacy you know
you say that the war Ukraine has made
Germans re-evaluate Russia a Chinese
re-evaluation I think hasn't quite come
yet and I think it's it's fascinating to
me how merkel's Legacy could be changing
even after she leaves office absolutely
and I think we only saw one side of the
coin I mean to be fair going and
covering 2017 election for instance and
going back in 2021
for The Spectator and other people too I
mean I never felt that the Germans were
quite as rosy-eyed as certain people as
Starry Eyed does certain people here in
um Britain were we tended to see the
kind of foreign policy she she presented
she was the right person at the right
time in terms of foreign policy as it
seemed then I mean obviously not now in
the light of Ukraine but um at the time
we tended to just see the foreign
possibly rather than the domestic pitch
it was a lot more mixed I think the
other thing to remember about Germany is
I mean the the system's very different
there in that not just in the business
tag and the German national Parliament
but all the way down it's a whole
network of coalitions
um and uh you know it's the the the
Constitution which you know partly is a
legacy of of of Britain's role in in
recreating Germany after the second
World War uh the bundles Republic
completely new country essentially
um is that it's almost impossible for
one for one party to to sort of drive
through everything they want to do all
four leader to I mean we tended to see
Germany equals Marco but actually on the
ground it was much more of a sort of
collective process and usually a case of
not just an abundance tag but also in
the regional parliaments as well
different parties working together and
of course the wild Cardinal is the rise
of um alternative for Deutschland FD and
the fact that this is a party uniquely
almost in in German politics modern
German politics that the other parties
won't work with and that is the big
question now because they're polling
something around 20 at the moment and
normally when a party gets to that level
that you'll find on reasonable level
even a national level you know they're
working with other parties and and you
know there are some quite unusual
alliances in German politics for
instance the CDU which is roughly
speaking the conservative party in in
Germany is is is working on well in
national government with the green party
and also you know historically a lot of
times they've they've they've done it
not not just on a national level but on
a regional level as well and yeah afd is
the one party that the other parties
weren't won't work with and um Friedrich
merch the
um uh CTU leader markle's successor in
uh that regard he then had to roll back
quite recently because he was saying
we're never going to work with these
people on a national level but you know
we have to maybe think about it if
there's a reason well he just kind of
floated the question floated the idea
really that of Poss the possibility of
working on on a local level and then had
to roll back on it very very clearly I
mean he never said he would but he just
kind of raised the idea and then the
reaction was quite strong but if you are
going to have a party which is polling
20 in a sort of you know system of
fortunate representation and uh
Coalition governments on Regional and
National levels then it's quite a big
step to say that if this part is on 20
we're not going to have anything to do
with them but that that is the situation
at the moment and that that is the big
debate in Germany at the moment is is
you know to you know should we ban these
people should we should be you know
think again whatever I mean I mean and
obviously it throws up a lot of um
difficult historical questions as well
but your point uh to people who are
concerned about the afd people who are
concerned about the economic slowdown is
that Germany has never been that perfect
but at the same time it can also
overcome these current issues which
frankly all modern democracies face yeah
I think so I mean I think what's
happening is that the CDU I mean this is
another thing the the Christians I make
Union the CDU Miracles party was always
a kind of heat fight conservative party
more than the factorite party but it was
a conservative party nonetheless and she
really took it bit by bit very gradually
uh for over 16 years now office but she
took it to the center ground away from
the center right to the center almost
made a kind of soft left party in some
respects now this was politically very
astute in terms of domestic politics and
that this really emasculated the SPD
which is the kind of Social Democratic
soft left party in Germany and kind of
you know stole a lot of their territory
and left them with nowhere to go but it
did open up the space on the right and
this space has been filled by afd I
think what's going to happen is the CDU
is and I think it's already starting to
happen is going to be moving back
towards becoming a center-right party
again and this will prevent there being
a really big Breakthrough by by afd I
think it will be more manageable but
it's it's still significant it's still
troubling and it's still a cause for
concern certainly
thank you
[Music]